[Music]
to promote this this film which you have
co-written and you starring you you've
been putting up childhood photos on
Twitter a week before the phone came out
I I tried to bribe people to see the
film by putting embarrassing photos of
myself
uh we saved one is this Ana photo than
Tamera - I thought this was sweet I
thought that was a sweet that's a photo
of you that I thought was really sweet I
don't know why you're embarrassed you're
tough look that's a tough look why the
the braces like perm hair turtleneck
combo I think it's not it's not that
sexy you know was a tough look I'm gonna
show you mine
look that's put mine up it's that's a
tough look right you're gorgeous we're
talking about that was me two years ago
no you're so you're so cute
but my hair was parted in the middle cuz
that's how all the cops were Don chips
very Estrada very ironic product by the
way you're way cooler than I am the
awkwardness factor is not high for you -
look at that
let's not do it up again oh look yeah
come on that's like I don't know when
grades in class I'm sure that you were
at least cool I'm that's a still of me
you don't then see me then move I would
shuffle around I was awkward I didn't
couldn't work my own body like
Frankenstein yeah I grew very quickly
and I had no control over my upper or
lower body and I had this for years did
you fair I had control over both parts
of my body you know when you drive past
a place that's selling cars and they
have that soft pink occasion that's
inspired by me that's how I moved as an
adolescent